малайзійський чи так боїнг mh17 був збитий
ірак цього комплексу бук російського
вирубні тесла випущений ois території до
пробувала під контролем проросійських
сепаратистів донецької області в процесі
роду на вигляд мало представники
міжнародного slide show групи
спирається на кримінальну
розслідування можемо вбиті виставку з
через mh17 був збитий та
17 усмішка 2014 року ракету із серії 9 м
8330 вісім випущена з комплексу бук оце
комплекс прибув з території російської
федерації та повернувся на територію
Російської Федерації після запуску
ті ви знову ґрунтуються знач нумерую на
експертизі у ланки
рейс мн17 ви увійти в амстердам а 17
липня 2014 року
вин прямого fda куала-лумпура і ви
бухнула палітрі ближче грабового на
донеччині дату поділася обома ж
українською скронею це проросійськими
сепаратистами заглянув і 290 листів людей
міжнародні експерти
аналізу валу різанини das lied дружина
свічення від шиви тиф та не зняти і
змориш мобільного зв'язку з у путна
повис ним до
радіолокації не так не та інша дука зайчик
їм його лаги та засоби rectum вже краще
вже виступала з промисловим зв там що
Чи так books би тієї самої російської
літерами протеїни поклала про війну на
якусі з torino ракета бук про і значимо
чи для збуту таким високу траєкторію
польоті mh17 летимо на висоті 10 тисяч
метрів тобто в зоні досягнувши снасті book
росія дня ми в к травить кинула свою
права названого краще візьму українських
ризикових у team данії цифри
славі, що вже на раз доводив і прикладом
раз слідував bellingcat
росіян і вже заявила, що на ви знаєте
результаті в міжнародному розслідуванні
злиту групи і кашу он і
нас викладають їх ним і